a kite's on the end of a string 80
meters long now
i'm gonna pause there for a second
that's a really long string um you might
notice i've already drawn up this rough
diagram and i haven't put any
information on it yet i'm gonna fill it
on as i read the question right so
here's my kite up the top here
there's my kite it's flying up in the
wind okay and the string
that's attached to the kite is 80 meters
long and i think it also does mention
assume the string is a straight line so
here is my 80 meter piece of string
is it a straight meaning
yeah straight like a straight
line string
the answer is no the answer is no
because if you keep on reading which
let's do that
in general yeah
if the vertical height of the kite aha
now we're talking about this distance
the vertical height of the kite from the
person uh from the ground sorry is 69
meters so there you go
there's
another length okay
now what's the actual question they're
asking for
find the angle of elevation
of the kite from the person
find the angle of elevation so here's
the person
okay
so
which angle is the angle of elevation in
this picture yeah
yeah it's the one at the person on the
left i guess is this this is what you're
approaching here okay right so you
remember
we have these um greek letters they're
kind of our convention for when we have
an angle but we don't know what it is
okay so i'm calling it theta all right
i should really call it 30 degrees
now how do i find out what the size of
the angle is that's the angle of
elevation okay i'm going to start off by
writing that um that mnemonic device we
used to remember yes i could talk good
the more times you write it the less
times you'll need to because it just
gets stuck into your head okay
at sign cars and tan
which ratio are you going to need this
time yeah so it's signed how do we know
good you can see you're starting to get
the hanger aren't you right
if this is the angle you got
this side is opposite and of course the
hypotenuse is the longest one
okay great so now we can write out a
number sentence an equation that matches
up to this right you said it was sine
sine of what
sine
of theta of that angle right yeah which
we don't know what it is yet okay so
that's fine you just write down theta
degrees
and it's opposite on hypotenuse that's
fine
there's the ratio that we've got okay
now this is different to the ones that
we looked at earlier because we're
trying to find an angle we're not trying
to find a length right so you need your
calculator for this again
what we're going to get is 30 degrees
equals okay now
to get the angle out of this right
i want to get rid of sine from this side
it's going to become sine
inverse or shift sign on your calculator
on this side right so
69 over
80. there you go and you can kind of
should spit out a number two what do you
get
sorry yeah why is there a minus one
after sign like yeah yeah okay so
so this this negative one i'll get your
number in a second right this negative
one means
it's the inverse or the reverse of sine
right so this undoes what this does
right which
so no no it's just the just the sign
it's what's gotten rid of right it's
just like
if you had say
example um the square root of x equals
five
you would square both sides here
wouldn't you and you'd get what's the
square of this
six it's just x
right and then you get 25 right so the x
hasn't come over just like the theta
hasn't come over it stays put so but if
we did um if we went to it sine and
theta both of the other sides would be
sine theta in inverse minus yeah you
could divide by the whole thing but
that's not what we're doing okay now
jake have you got a number for us can
you read it out for us
okay that's cool all right good so you
got a whole bunch of decimals there
right now look carefully at what the
question is asking you it says
oh sorry yes okay
okay now before you answer before you
know how to approximate you've got to
look at how the question wants you to
approximate right and it says
answer to the nearest minute
nearest minute now
you've got to think back to last term on
this one we dealt with these right
minutes are a way of dividing up degrees
okay so just like you divide up hours
right into minutes
and seconds
right it's exactly the same kind of
division we're dividing up not hours but
degrees which is why some of your
calculators
will have a dms button right which
divides things up in exactly this way
okay so with this still on your display
right you want to hit the degrees
minutes seconds button which is the one
it looks like this if you remember this
i think it's something like this
all right so you then get another number
what's the readout
59 degrees degrees yep 35 minutes 35
wait anything else after that and then
54.43
okay
i'll just write out the whole thing and
it has this yeah
okay good so
look at it with me right i'll even get
another color out okay it's degrees
minutes seconds right you recognize
that's the um
that's the symbol for degrees right the
next one is a symbol for minutes and the
next one is the symbol for seconds okay
now be super super careful here right
you've got degrees minutes seconds i
want to the nearest minute okay to the
nearest minute
so this is either going to stay 35
or it's going to go up to 36.
should it go up or down
it should go up that's exactly right
it's going to be 59 oops sorry 59
degrees
36 minutes
okay now
it goes up you're kind of lucky on this
one right because why did you tell me
why are you so sure that it goes up yeah
well i know i'm about to say it because
it's usually above 50 but in this case
it's 30. yeah okay all right so
good let's rewind a little bit just in
case you weren't there yet right usually
if you see something like
30.1
uh
give an example one
five
okay
if i said round this to one decimal
place round to one decimal place
actually i'll give you an even easier
number okay if you were to round this to
one decimal place what would you get
one decimal place right
so the 30 is going to stay there and
it'll be 0.2 good that's fine and the
reason why is because you've got this 1
6 and it goes up right now if i give you
another number 30.13
okay and i'll ask you again to round it
right one way or the other this time
it's going to round
down okay good and the reason why is
because the threshold is is five five is
the middle this is above five this is
below five and that's the results okay
so what's the five selfies
um well by convention
unless you're unless you're a banker it
goes up i'll talk about that another
time now here's the problem though here
you'd think oh 54 out of like what we
usually would think decimal so 54 is
like out of 100 right but there are 100
seconds in a minute
there are only 60 seconds in a minute
right so let me just give you a
different example suppose
instead of this being on the readout
okay you got this 59 degrees 35 minutes
and
32 seconds
okay now if you saw this 30.13 you'd say
okay round down no problems okay
but look this is seconds is this closer
to 60 seconds or is it closer to zero
seconds the answer is it's closer to a
whole minute than not a minute right so
this that would round down
right sorry that would round up that's
what i was saying there you go okay just
like this rounds up so you've got to be
careful that's why this was the answer i
had on the board at the end of
the day